hey what's up welcome back to my channel
my name's samuel leeds and this is yet
another winners on a wednesday and you
are in for a treat today i want to
introduce you to a guy called josh
who has done absolutely incredible
things in property
he's come to the crash course he went
through the academy and over the last
sort of year and a half
he's built up a large property portfolio
of renter rents properties that he owns
he's sourcing he's completely
financially free so you're gonna enjoy
welcome josh to the show how you doing
i'm great i'm great how are you
so you you said that you felt weird
coming into the house because you've
seen
that many times you've seen this i feel
like i've watched so many videos i've
seen
inside the house been actually been
inside yeah so uh it's
uh yeah it's great to be here i really
appreciate you having me and i know
you've done a lot of business with
academy members some of your closest
friends have been on windows on a
wednesday
yeah chris chap chris jack david taylor
anthony
uh yeah patrick whoa there's so many and
that's the thing i think it's like
environment is everything yeah it's just
so predict if you want to be successful
you want it to be predictable
hang around successful people yeah and
that is it i think that was probably the
biggest thing that i've had out the
academy
alongside the training it's the people
i've met yeah all those relationships
wouldn't have happened without that and
uh yeah to to now be here it's uh it's a
it's good for you and every time anyone
ever speaks of you just they're always
speaking like really highly of you
you know the other trainers alistair the
people within the academy
and i know we've met quite a lot i've
seen you at the training programs and
stuff but it's just great to sit down
with you and get to talk
so why don't you start by just kicking
off what's your background and
why property okay so my background i was
previously working in engineering
in the engineering industry i was a
business development manager i was
constantly going up and down country
um but i've always in the back of mind i
always wanted to start a business just
wasn't
too sure what in and i knew from
from the job that i wasn't really going
to achieve the goals that i'd set out
for myself
or achieve the lifestyle i wanted for me
me family by
working that nine-to-five job yeah um
and then ever since then it was always
researching online uh books
and then i always seen property as i
always got taught the property was more
of a buy to let theme
she had to have about 25 to put on the
property that's your first one
so i always sort of overlooked that and
then uh
through online research and trying
different things next minute i'll come
across one of your videos
which was i think it was a video of you
was sitting in office and going through
all the different strategies that you
could do in property and that was it
then
managed blown because i thought well no
that can't be right i can't be right
how's how's that
and then i was i was in um i probably
went through all your videos within one
week got the books
uh and next minute i'm on the on the
crash course in birmingham
um and and doing all that fun stuff
um and then from being on the crash
course again it was eye opening
he was talking on stage about how we can
do this this this and all these
different strategies that
i couldn't take enough notes down um and
next minute then i'm on there i'm on the
dfa and we're
we're again back in birmingham on this
on the three-day course and
it's just completely eye-opening so i
think a really interesting napoleon hill
says
when you can conceive it yeah and then
believe it
then you'll receive it yeah and i guess
a lot of people in property they can't
even conceive what's possible
you know some of the things that you can
do through rent to rent and deal
sourcing and
you know flips different there's so many
different strategies which is way beyond
as you say which is way beyond just
buying a house renting it out but the
first step is to conceive it
you see you can can see that it's
possible then to believe it
were you ever skeptical did you at any
point think this is too good to be true
this isn't possible
yeah a lot of you you're sort of the
chimp
i've only read the book of trump paradox
but it's always a chimp on the shoulder
yeah
um this can't be right you know watching
youtube videos thinking on the crash
course
still can't be right then from actually
speaking to previous students whilst on
the crash course
which we then signed up to the fa um
just
more and more the more you get involved
more and get engaged that you realize
actually this can happen yeah and
there's multiple case studies
videos just like this you know watching
when it's on a wednesday
um and all the time there's always that
doubt
that what if what if what if did you
know when you're watching women's
wednesday videos that you'd end up being
a year or so later you'd end up being on
the show probably
not as soon as what i thought i thought
yeah i'd like to see myself on there
three or four years time
and and then i'll see half that so
it's uh it's very strange as a as a
concept perspective to see that but
all the time yeah you always get that
doubt in your mind constantly thinking
yeah this can't be right this can't be
right i know when did you quit your job
so this had this such a good story so i
quit my job
in october i'm very much an all or
nothing guy i'm that's it i'm in
um so it's sort of as we
relaxed on on the covered side um it was
october time
and even then i remember putting my
resonation in i was last day of work i
thought
i shouldn't be doing this this is this
feels wrong this is this is not how it's
supposed to be
um and i'd had my last day of work
two days later i was going on the deal
cell master class
um and actually on that course i'd sold
a deal on the course
wow and then at that point then i
thought i should remember that
yeah and you told me on the day yeah
yeah i think i uh
i sort of quickly walked to the back and
said this what just happened i couldn't
believe it and then that
since that point then i thought right i
can do something with this this is the
right business model for me
property can look touch feel it you know
i've been to view the property
a week beforehand um
yeah i just knew i could do something
with it so when you quit your job
had you done any deals previously or did
you quit it in faith
uh i think i'd done one and it was
sort of imbalanced but the majority was
on faith
so what were you saying was in balance
what what do you mean um
because the we went to sell it and the
landlord just found another vendor for
it
okay it was always like that really full
throw it fell through so basically you
had a deal it kind of fell through yeah
so when you quit your job
that must have been pretty scary not of
seeing money come in the bank yet yeah
because it
like say that the job i previously
wasn't to be charged away from it's a
very very good job how much we paid
uh it was on forty thousand yeah
and how old are you
25. okay so 25 on a 40 grand a year job
as an engineer
with a company car lots of perks lots of
security
and then you literally quit that
in faith that this property stuff's
gonna work out that sounds a little bit
risky i probably wouldn't have even
recommended that at the time i would
have been like just wait just wait
what what and you liked your job i like
my job yeah it was nothing
so why did you quit because again i knew
it wasn't going to achieve what i wanted
to do
it wasn't going to the goals that set
myself from what seeing me lifestyle
being like
i'd envisioned what i wanted to do and
what i wanted to have and everything
else
um i thought that's it and what year was
this
this was in october last year 2020 so
literally just a few months ago
you're in your job and you quit that's
crazy so talk me through then
what happened on the deal selling
masterclass that was so profound that
that was the day you actually made money
what happened um
well it was obviously we've been trained
to
all the students and everything else um
and i was there was on stage you know he
was uh
selling from stage of his deals and
showing how he's
he sends out to his network and
everything else um
actually someone that was on the course
was looking for a deal
and it just happened that i had i had
one that suited
so he sort of pulled me aside and said
you know what we got tell me
about it um and then i think over
breakfast the next morning
just before going to the course uh we
we've got the deal over the line he was
made up absolutely made up which was
even a bigger benefit for me to see
you know we've just added to his
portfolio yeah it's also
been a service that we've provided as
well and the business is flourishing
from it how much did he pay
uh he paid 2500. okay so nice little
faith
nice little fear so since quitting your
job yeah let's talk about deal sources
to begin with because i know you've done
loads of other stuff and now you're
moving on to developments and all sorts
yeah but deal sourcing yeah how much
have you made consecutively
from october until now uh on average
between seven
seven eight grand a month seven and
eight grand so considerably more than
your job
exactly and i've seen your your money
come in as well i've seen this with the
screenshots
um what amelia sent me and it's like
built up and built up as well hasn't it
yeah it was like three
four four five and then suddenly bang
2021 january
just went crazy just went crazy i think
it we're i'm
based in liverpool and the mark in
liverpool at the moment i know you've
got property in liverpool as well
yeah the market's crazy and we're trying
we're fulfilling at the moment as a
business
quite a lot of demand yeah but it's it's
very good for us all right deal sourcing
yeah how do you find your investors um
i go through multiple multiple avenues
uh off through social media through
networking events
courses crash courses everywhere really
you never know
a lot of a lot of the uh investors have
just been through networking okay
next question you meet me at a
networking event yeah
what do you say to me i'm an investor
i'm there we're at a crash course or
we're at an academy event or a business
dinner whatever it might be
you know i'm an investor yeah hi how you
doing we're a bit so we have a bit of a
chit chat yeah
what do you say how do you get me in
your world um
well start off by saying you know why
how are you here what what you're
looking for
um and then going into the conversation
then is well if you could find something
in liverpool what would that look like
and then start starting right into uh
into what they're looking for
um and say well actually this is a
service that we provide and this is some
of the things that we've worked on
previously
would that be of interest cool and then
it progresses on from there so just
very conversational oh you're an
investor what are you looking to buy
oh great okay well i'm actually a deal
source so i've got i've got some
potential
this is the kind of thing i'm working on
without your interest great yeah candy
card i'll put you on an
email list have a wonderful rest of the
evening yeah really chilled
okay how do you find the deals um it
deals
more so now we find a lot of off-market
deals yeah um
because the market's very abundant at
the moment a lot of off-market through
our relationships we built with estate
agents in the area
that's very very good one of our biggest
ones as well has been through
uh friends family or estate age people
that estate agents know
they're not probably don't bring it to
the market as well yeah a lot of
off-market ones
um so off-market how do you get in with
estate agents how do you get them to
pass you those off because a lot of
people will say oh i
asked the estate agent you can't just
say to an estate agent hey do you mind
passing me the juicy off market deals
please
it's not like that yeah there's there's
a process to it right
there is it's just building up that
rapport with them and having confidence
i've always seen
it as if they if you sat down in front
of the estate agent and you said
if you've got any off market deals then
you're probably not just going to give
them to
if you can sit down with them and you'll
you can bring confidence you can bring
to the table
look this is what i've got things in
principle i've got clients here waiting
this is
you know you can back up what you're
going to say you're going to do that
massively makes a massive difference to
yeah
to that for them to have confidence in
you as well yeah it's a relationship
thing it works both ways what's the best
way to build a good relationship with an
agent
and buying flowers right
well you bought me flowers today yeah
well there you go there you go um
is just be the best friend yeah simply
um cons consistent with them be
confident with them
become the best what i've seen you do as
well um which which is something that i
say a lot is
is the best way to build a relationship
with an agent is to buy from them
yeah right so it snowballs and you've
bought from a lot of agents off market
and then the deals keep pouring in
yeah meanwhile the investors the bought
from you keep wanting to buy i get by
again
so i think your first deal is always
your hardest
definitely you did your first one the
deal selling master class you then quit
your job
yeah so you've been building up a
massive deal sourcing company which is
awesome
how was the deal city masterclass by the
way very good um
uh i'd say unbelievable because even at
the course i think austere actually
dragged me on stage and i wrote out the
email
to send out to his investors to
to say what the deals were and to see
that live on stage you know there's not
not many things that you see that
happens live you can see the phone calls
happening with the investors
um that's how i knew yeah again i could
do something with this
so again it's like seeing it being done
being introduced to people
having other investors around other deal
sources and actually just being in an
environment where you're seeing it
yeah yeah backing backing up what it
says the same the agents
just having confidence backing up with
what you say you're going to do yeah
what are the training programs that
you've been on
uh so i've done the full academy so the
rents weren't revolution
uh business and property investing
still selling masterclass as you know um
uh one of the biggest ones i went on was
tell the world as well yeah which
enabled me to uh to have contents when i
speak actually speak on stage at
one of the crash courses amazing which
again rule number one for being a
property investor is to tell the world
your property investor yeah you know and
it's been great seeing your growth
as well over the last sort of year or so
um okay
so from all the different strategies
you've gone on you've not just packaged
us all deals you've also
done a lot of other stuff yeah so what
else have you done outside of
packaging and selling deals well uh as i
start
the the next one would be the rent
service accommodations
so at the moment we've got two
apartments in birmingham we've got one
in bristol
uh and jointly we've got eight in
liverpool as well
incredible um which uh which we're all
doing all doing really well
um especially again since staycations
are now opening up
yeah um that was that's rent service
accommodation we're also
looking after a lot of project
management as well for some of our
clients we've done brrs for
um we've often complete hands off
investment they don't need to worry
about it and we've done the project from
start to finish
bro on all and you guys have delivered
such a good job and i've
i've i've seen you guys at start i've
met chris as well who's
in business with and you know i'm really
impressed with your work ethic and how
you've
just gone the extra mile to get the job
done yeah so okay
deal sourcing you can make crazy money
every month you know i think what was
you what's your best month deal sourcing
uh it was fifteen thousand
fifteen grand some people would say why
do anything else
why not just deal source and make 15
grand a month or even more scale up
so what's the difference between talk to
me about the difference between that
deal sourcing active income and then the
recurring income from rent to rent and
why you want both
uh so the reason why i wanted to both is
deal sourcing broke a bit capital and
cash flow
um but with regards to the rent to rent
it wants to go into that because it
brought a bit more passive once it was
set up with management companies once
the finishes were in place the claims
were in place it then became a bit more
passive which is what i was looking for
that consistent
income um one of my biggest reasons why
is always to
to sort of help with my family um and
you know
i'm pleased to sit here and say now that
as of friday
i managed to get me all my work so he's
now started into the business into the
clinic
and that's huge for you it's massive
that was that was my reason why
talk to me a bit more about that why was
that so important to you um
because like saying your mom and dad he
uh he's always provided for family
and very much so um and
after being in the corporate life for
over 34 years always wants to try and
help him get out of that and also see
the different light
he also joined me on the first crash
course as well um
so it was always that was always the
mission to try and do that
and that's why i didn't just stay with
deal source and wanted the passive
income to
help replace our income so we could then
so not only have you become financially
free but you've been able to get your
dad out of work yeah
how did he has he handed his nose in his
last day of work was friday so he's
totally finished he's totally finished
he's done
um yeah unbelievable how does he feel
it's it's a bit of a break breaking the
system because it's 34 years you know
what
i remember when i finished that was
after eight years or so
yeah um i thought that was strange so
he's
you know 34. that's unbelievable yeah um
so yeah but he's absolutely made up and
he can see see the business see what
you're trying to do
because this business this property
business that that you've built
it's not funny it's not just fun and
games it's not like a bit of
it's not a side hustle no it's this
isn't a side hustle this is and if you
treat it like a cycle so you'll get side
hustle results
and that was the whole thing you know
you asked me about why did i go
all in straight from the off yeah and
that was it because i think if
you treat treated like a side hustle
then it is a side hustle yeah whereas if
you go all in
then it is it's a uh it's an all-in
business yeah
and you know we wasn't there just to do
a couple of deals and that'll be it
we're here to make a property business
and go into development which is now
what we
are doing amazing told me about the
development side of things
and i've just given you my new book i
know i remember
yeah i think you're one of the first
people to share that around as well so
thanks for that yeah the second it came
out
no it's uh it's it's great to see you
know it really really is and
i think i found my nighttime reading now
so uh it's it's come at the right time
but
yeah we're starting into developments
we've got a lot of a lot of things in
the pipeline
and interestingly a lot of investors
come forward now and said that they want
to work with us
and get them get involved and join
ventures they're seeing what we're doing
you know we we've backed up what we can
say we're going to do with the projects
um on the br side yeah so now the next
stage is to go and stay awesome
awesome and i'm pretty sure i said i
think he might be in the deal saying
mastercats or what one of the training
programs i talked about how
if you've got a list of investors yeah
and you've got and you've got a list of
deals
you can package and sell deals but once
you start packaging selling deals lots
you can then go actually
why don't i just use the investors money
and joint venture with them and then you
start building your own pie
that's it that's it and now that's what
people are starting to
starting to want to do because they're
seeing the returns that we're getting
for the people we've seen we've got
testimonials there we've got case
studies uh
it's uh it's a perfect win-win for them
we can put the time
in and they can help finance them and
obviously they get the return what would
you say to somebody that was saying
you can't find buy refurbished finance
deals in this market
keep looking best where do you look give
us some tips
at the moment for me is off market
really get involved with um
state agents building up them
relationships ask family friends
relatives people
someone whoever you speak to someone
will know someone that's got something
they've got problem with property
yeah and the biggest things that you
always told me was use all these
strategies as a toolbox and become a
property problem solver
correct and that is it um everyone knows
someone that's got a property
and become that problem solver for them
um
so yeah keep looking look off market be
creative
you know with the letters um think how
you can make yourself different
we're currently in liverpool at the
moment it's probably one of the most
buoyant markets
in the uk um but just be
different be creative look at what you
can do
that other people may not be doing
that's that's the main thing
that's great how's life now how does it
feel to not have a job to go to and to
be just full time in the business
um still although it was backing up so a
bit surreal really because
uh you are your own boss you know um
and you know to to see the family that's
happy
and everything else um i'm doing
something you enjoy as well i think
anyone that
don't want to watch this or they want to
go into property um
you've got to really got to enjoy it
you've got to be enthusiastic and be
able to
get out there and do it but it's it's
very very different but also very very
good
now when you came to tell the world um
part of what we teach and tell the world
is is is being able to speak out tell
everybody what you're doing
and since then you started your very own
podcast with chris jack who's also an
academy member yeah so
talk to me a little bit about the reason
behind that and what your visions are
for that
so the visions for that and the reason
why we started it um yeah the property
pals podcast
we started that to realize since when we
started the
we've got a lot of hints and tips that
and little golden nuggets that
we may not uh share with everyone and we
wanted to try and do that through the
podcast
but also get on experienced property
investors and developers
that have got all these little golden
nuggets that they may not read in a book
or anything else
um and try and extract that as much as
possible so anyone listening
can sort of pick up on them you know
we've just done an episode now about
abbreviations i remember starting now i
thought abbreviations with
these are uh such a complex thing
so hopefully anyone that's listening to
it and starting out on the journey
they can pick up any these little things
these little acronyms these little
golden nuggets
from ourselves and from our guests and
yeah just enjoy it have fun with it
that's awesome and
and as well i think when you're um out
doing deals i don't know if you're
anything like me but i'll learn
something because you're learning all
the time
when you do deals yeah and and and for
me i'll like rush home to my wife or
whoever and i'm like oh you never got
what happened today
and and i i want to share my day and for
me doing youtube videos
and whether it'd be podcasts it's kind
of the same thing it's just like sharing
my day and sharing what's happened
but at the same time you've been on
you've been on teleworld training and
stuff and
it's also you're building your brand
exactly it's
that's something i've learned over the
past six months as well building that
personal brand yeah put yourself out
there
since going on tell the world um i
probably wasn't doing it as much as what
i should have been
yeah but that's really kickstarter that
a prime example you know
we spoke to a developer last week and he
had all these reeling off all these
little golden nuggets and tips and
things
it was second nature to him but it's
about trying to share that share that
story
and share it amongst our our audience so
hard question now yeah what would be
some of the top three
golden nuggets that you've learned over
the not just not just the training but
actually
the doing because you know it's i think
it's like um
you know they say when you really learn
to drive a car is after you pass your
test
yeah so you you drive you learn to drive
but you know you're a bit stuff in a bit
but then after you pass your test and
you get all that experience
that's when you really learn to drive
and in the same way i think when you're
going through training and stuff yes
you're doing it
yeah and we'll make you it's not just
theory but once you've finished through
the academy and you've built some
properties
then you really learn yeah you know so
you've been out in the deep end you've
been doing a lot of different deals brr
deals and flips now moving into
development you've got rent events
management tenants packaging deals
investors estate edges
a lot of stuff there yeah what being
some of the biggest learning curves
you've learned actually on the road
doing stuff as opposed to training
uh the biggest one first biggest one is
what i mentioned earlier on um
using don't forget you're a property
problem solver that's one of the one of
the biggest things because
it's quite easy to say right i'm going
to go down rent to rent and that's all
i'm going to be doing
or i'm going down deal source i just
want package deals and that's it
always look about how he can solve
people's problems how he can diversify
how he can get involved with with
everything um
because that that fundamentally that's
what you're trying to do
the second one uh would be to network
like hell
um get in front of people
network meet people use what they've got
use the knowledge you know one of the
biggest things that
that we're doing at the moment is i have
an accountability group every monday
yeah and just being around those guys
the six of us
just being around those guys really
it's virtually one because it's a little
bit competitive but what views on this
week what
you know what we're trying to achieve so
get around good people network
um and then finally the third one
is just get out there just do it just go
for it yeah
um say yes worry about it later yeah
that's that's sometimes you can
overthink things
like coming on winners wednesday like
come on when it's wednesday
um but you do overthink things to just
get out there say yes
yeah and go so true so three points
number one
is is be a problem solver that's such an
important point because when you know
the strategies
and and you know i sort of explain like
this you haven't got a strategy you've
got multiple strategies up your sleeve
and you just ask you go and view houses
and say how can i help
and depending on what they say you pull
out the card and you deal it um
and then it's people it's people
business and and unless you're saying
yes taking action
yeah i think that's massive there's so
many people that just
study the youtube videos and yeah don't
ever do anything
but if you're right move all the time
then yeah yeah do anything with it
but if you're not in in front or around
people that are also doing it if you're
in the wrong environment wrong energy
you never it's never really really going
to happen so okay cool so what would be
your
um what would you say to somebody that
was thinking about coming along to a
crash course
that had that little chimp you know the
little be careful voice on that
what would your first hand advice be
probably flick the chimp off your
shoulder
yeah just get yourself down they've got
nothing to lose absolutely nothing to
lose
get amongst it get amongst the people
even if you go down there and you meet
loads of new people and you just network
with them and you get in touch with them
um just be around that atmosphere yeah
you can't describe it
until you're there and once you're there
you'll think about a chimp you think
why didn't it just come sooner yeah why
didn't i do it yeah um
because it's not all on youtube get down
to crash rules take action yeah it's not
it's not it can't be all on youtube
no no and that you can't get the
environment from youtube either no
it's that that's the the people the
space the energy
and also the concise way of teaching and
the and the accountability
like when we say here's how you do a
deal and everyone goes oh that's good
and they'll write it down and go
now go do it but that's what you've got
yeah so
all right awesome what you've done is
incredible really proud of you and also
the guys and the people that you've
worked with
um if someone wants to reach out and get
in touch obviously there's the podcast
which we can we can tune into which is
property pals
property pals podcast yeah awesome uh
and connect me on social media just
josh r jenkins um and also if you want
to get
access to and see our website that is
dconic.com
amazing thanks so much for coming on the
show thank you for having me really
appreciate it again so welcome
so there we go that's josh jenkins check
him out hit him up on instagram
and follow his story but again week
after week after week
more inspiring stories and they say the
same thing they say
take massive action and i'd like you to
take massive action right now
i want you to book onto the crash course
it's free
what have you got to lose i'll leave a
link in the description
get booked on we want to meet you we
want to see you grow and maybe one day
you'll be sat on the chair having a chat
with me as well until next time
have a wonderful wonderful evening you
can watch a whole
playlist of people on winners on a
wednesday but don't keep watching them
just you become one of them by coming to
the crash course
subscribe and i'll see you real soon
thanks and peace